cela faisait cinquante ans qu'il
traînait dans un tiroir du bureau de ce
lédonien après tout ce temps jean louis
moustillon ancien journaliste au journal
le progrès a décidé de faire développer
ses négatifs des photos de l'enterrement
du général de gaulle à colombey les deux
églises
lorsque j'ai voulu essayer de les faire
connaître au public je me suis dit il
faut que je les fasse tirer
ça a été un peu un exploit de trouver
quelqu'un qui puisse gérer ses photos
alors que j'ai eu la possibilité pendant
des années de le faire le 12 novembre
1970 charles de gaulle est enterré dans
cette petite commune de la haute marne
à l'époque jean-louis moustillon à 21
ans et il est en garnison au 400 3e
régiment d'artillerie à la base aérienne
de chaumont-semoutiers des camarades
sont réquisitionnés pour prêter main
forte lors des obsèques
il décide donc de confier à un soldat un
appareil photo j'étais à 30 km de cet
événement je ne pouvais pas y aller mais
j'ai estimé qu'il fallait que je me
débrouille pour avoir quelques photos
pour moi garder quelque chose d'ailleurs
voilà comment ça s'est passé j'étais pas
loin
au final on trouve plusieurs clichés de
militaires le sourire aux lèvres portant
les gerbes de fleurs envoyées par des
personnalités comme mao tsé toung ou de
joséphine baker ou encore ces photos de
philippe de gaulle et du général de
boissieu
si ses camarades n'ont jamais pu voir
les images jean louis moustillon espère
un jour les retrouver afin de partager
ensemble ce petit bout d'histoire